[Music]
Runk hey guys Phoenix is on sale
Sacramento is on sale ALB Albuquerque
and El Paso I'll also be in Brea
California Oxnard California and reading
and no this will probably come out after
that uh well maybe not Philadelphia I
got a bunch of dates coming up go to
chris.com and then check out my special
grow or die at chia.com you can go
stream it now uh the links are all
provided below and uh I guess that's it
you know I decided uh this is well you
know I usually do a solo thing and uh
I've never really had anybody on this
podcast except for my family and also
David Sullivan but uh he our family yeah
kind of in a way well he's not
technically he come he came to our
Thanksgiving I know but I'm Italian so
it's like family is family you know oh
so when you say stuff like to Calvin
Orly talk to the microphone we said to
Calvin Orly like there're are family too
and the Italian eny goes like this nah
not for nothing but no they're not but
anyway uh this is this is my family uh
welcome Kristen to the podcast um
because I wanted to have her on and
that's that's that part of the reason
why uh I wanted to have her on is to
shake things up but also I know a lot of
you sometimes like when she comes on um
but also Christmas is coming up and she
loves Christmas so I figured that we
could do some sort of a Christmas thing
but then also she loves Christmas and so
she decided to without even really me
knowing decorate for Christmas in my
podcast now you love decorating talking
to the microphone make it was okay but
make sure it's just close to your mouth
it's got to be close to your mouth
before you don't have it on your teeth
now okay hey babe what's up wow um so
yeah but so I'm talking I I know but I'm
just saying you're stressing me out but
you like you like to but you like to
decorate oh yeah it's my absolute Jam
wow there is nothing wider than what you
just said seeing you the way you said it
in this in this aesthetic that's my
absolute Jam these are really the so
thing I want to show by the way you look
great thanks I have my DC yeah I saw it
yeah I saw the other one yeah what are
they they're both the same they're uh uh
ornaments oh yeah yeah what are they you
know like I'm Calvin I know well cuz I
know some people just listen oh I see
she knows what's up dude describe them
yeah so all right well Christmas is
coming up and that's cool and uh let me
do a little ASMR description for the
audio listeners of what of what the
podcast looks like right now ASMR oh
like you're going to whisper it yeah
okay so welcome to the new Christmas
podcast studio for this episode we have
a beautiful runner on the desk that's
green and white Tweed kind of woven
together I have a mama Claus coffee cup
we have some twinkly candles on on the
desk a beautiful fur faux Christmas tree
behind us a Merry Christmas um picture
some bells and a a Christmas thing and a
snowman so pissed my toddler is very
upset that I moved yeah um okay that was
good I don't know if that counts as ASMR
but you know it's nice and you are in
your element when you're in a thing like
this this is crazy how honestly I am
like a man and a lot of men listen to
this podcast and they're like [__] yeah
Chris Le's the man I am not the man here
right now you decorated my [__] like
Christmas and I didn't even know really
I came in and I'm like okay cool and a
lot of people are going to think hey
Crystal is [__] made because of this I
would actually think see that's if
they're like beta males no it's not
there's no no let me let me if they're
like not fully um in their manhood that
is what they would think if they're
fully in their manhood they're like wow
that's amazing that he's at a place
where like his wife is doing these
things and they're creating these things
together and they're happy together you
just described a woman and that is what
a woman thinks a man thinks like a look
at this [__] [__] you know the producer
nodded but I don't but yeah but and I
don't but I don't I don't it it's fine
I'm like I'm on my [__] made [__] when
I'm on it like I'm fine with it but uh
there are dudes are going to be like a
[__] f look at this and they're going to
be pissed but like and that's fine but
they just got to wait till next episode
because I'll clean this [__] out I'll
make it more dude next episode I'm going
to come back there's going to be all
sorts of [__] like uh there's going to
be like uh Phil Collins posters and I'm
just going to be the man but that would
require you to do something I'm not
going to do I'm going to ask you to do
it yeah and or you know whatever I don't
know but here's the thing like I'm
thinking of like caveman manly men if
they went back to the cave and it was
just men yeah first of
all well yeah that would be gay sure and
second of all if they came back to their
cave it would be like trashed and dirt
everywhere the fact that like a man
could go out and hunt and get your elk
bring it back and then the cave is like
nice and cozy and warm because his wife
made it that way that's the C man wife
made it that way but also to bag a wife
like that no I understand but you you
also literally bagged a wife back then
you'd put her in a bag and drag her to
your your your your uh Cave um but no I
don't I I get it but I also think
that you're describing a woman still you
don't first of all no men say they only
want men around right there's no parties
where it's like dude no chicks allowed
only dudes someone like that who some
babe your Hangouts are like that but
that's
not yeah but I okay so I'm married
though but like I'm saying when when
somebody is just a single dude they're
just they don't want only dudes around
sure yeah and then also if you put that
dude in an apartment or in a house and
you say hey bro single guy do whatever
you want that house is going to stay
like that and they're going to have a
couch in the TV and that's it m and
that's sad no okay but it's sad but to
you a woman to a guy the guy's going to
go like this what you're going to you
say you you're going to decorate this
and guys going go like this
what it's all done got the TV got the
couch I know and that's really like the
flaw in the male psyche that's the flaw
in the male py I mean there's so many
but like there are but we're
talking there's something about but I
[__] do crazy with this pistol squats
though babe no we're not going there yet
there's so many things that men feminize
and and decide that like that's not well
yeah of course manly just like crying
sure but like I'm saying also like
making your house nice and warm and cozy
it's considered a feminine thing so like
my experience as a girl living with
other girls shout out I'm trying to
think my last my last roommate Lauren
Perkins sweetie Angel also very hot and
oh we should do dating show we should do
a dating show yeah have her be like our
Bachelorette that's okay this is
congratulations the podcast that's
something completely different that I
also don't want to do be a nice little
twist anyways when I was living with
Lauren like I remember we would decorate
for the holidays and we would have
nights where we would just stand we
drink a glass of wine we do our laundry
together I maybe slept in my own bed
twice I would only sleep in her bed and
she would sleep in yours yeah we'd
cuddle and youle sleep in opposite beds
we just wanted to be you're not getting
the joke God God damn it she's in her in
her Nostalgia I'm saying she's s in your
bed and you s in her
bed like at different time at the same
time I get it okay well no it's not that
funny but you you have to at least
acknowledge it sure sure sure sure
anyway we did this and we cut all so do
it and it was lovely and like imagine a
guy coming home and like crying in his
roommate's lap like that's an
impossibility I would come home and just
have like a little bit of a hard day and
just be like hold me and she hold me and
it was so lovely and warm and cozy dude
men need to it's that's not uh Embrace
coziness but what about the like being
like sick with
it and like
dope what about like coming home and
being all like yo that day was so shitty
all I want to do is ball out all I want
to do is get some [__] I'm not even
into this but some dudes might be like
spinach
dip the Tostitos and I want to watch the
game I don't watch the game but that's
like a dude they like [__] and
someone goes like this how was work and
you go like this what shut up dude look
it's third down that's what they do
because let me tell you something man
it's so you have to I guess experience
what it is you're actually feeling but
man I be damn do you because you could
just no you could just be like hey
problems get out of here I don't do I
have problems yeah but do I yeah no and
you know what babe I'm gonna bow out
with the spinach dip that worked out F
fantastic for say I'm saying you can you
can do that though there are guys who do
that successfully and then just like die
at like 82 I Didn't Do It successfully I
obviously you know I a lot of my [__] is
like arms length humor humor you know
like
like but like when it comes to dudes
yeah they can do that
successfully uhuh for 80 85 years and
then just be like I was a dude peace
out and then yeah the wife is like oh
man but here's the thing I wish she
cried more no that's actually not what
happens what happens is the guy
celebrates his 20th wedding anniversary
and then he goes to work and then he
comes home with a note saying that she
left because she's been asking for the
same things for 20 years and he's just
been bearing it and not listening to her
and so then he is sad and lonely for the
last 20 years but I will too many Laura
Lin movies dud oh my God but I I do
agree well most women initiate divorces
I think it's like 70% and the majority
of them site ex exhaustion yeah but
that's because women are always
exhausted you know why cuz they love
busying themselves with
[__] they do dude they always do [__]
like g g how many CH how many women ring
that Bell behind you so I can start
boxing you no how many how many women go
like this uh uh the kids and I had to
take the thing and then we had to do
this any and okay and really the only
thing you have to do is the [__] you
have to do but women will be like H you
have no idea I had to go find Uggs oh my
God I had to go get the the plants to
give to the lady because to say thank
you you don't even need to do all that
[__] and then they'll be like you know
what I'm so exhausted from all the [__]
that I made up I'm going to divorce my
husband yeah and we're the Bad Guy honey
I know you're joking but like what
percentage of you for real believes
that that guy that Meme who was that I
don't know I I'll find it that's a meme
yeah what is it yellow Su oh oh oh spice
Adams he's funny um what percentage of
me believes that oh dude well no you
would have to say what percentage of
women do I think are like that no cuz
that's a it'd be a ridiculous it'd be a
ridiculous thing to think that even one
woman was completely like that but there
are yeah I guess you're right dude there
are you're telling me Oh God damn dude I
mean half of women are probably like
that
Christopher fighting words but you're
not like that I hope but like but like
what do you mean you hope you've known
me for seven years no no no but but yeah
I'm saying you can still leave me but
I'm saying like because of exha you
because of exhaustion because but really
what it is is you went to Michaels too
many times the craft store you you stop
doing that
dude that imagine after all we've been
through if that if that was like how you
rectified it in your head cuz you
couldn't come to grips with your own
like consequences that you face and
you're like you know what she just went
to Michaels too many times and left my
ass Michael is a craft store that she's
going all go to all the time and it's
she's not going to leave me because of
exhaustion because it's not no no no
because that's the [__] women are
gatherers and they take a bunch of [__]
and they [__] gather and they got to
go out and get the stuff and well the
guys are the hunters but the women
gathered all together and before you
know it they're like oh man this is too
much I divorce you and it's not even the
dude a lot of women do it yes next
topic dear Lord please help me get
through this in peace without strangling
my husband my sweet husband who I still
love amen dear Lord please let me get
through this in in
pieces Well here here's where I think
you're F but see but okay and I want to
hear this trust me I really want to hear
this but I am
so done with this conversation and go
ahead and no no no no no I don't even
mean like moving on I mean like keep
going but like I think I am done paying
attention
sure but I'm I'm but I'm I'm being which
would be a reason if you did that
consistently that women would leave it
talk to the micophone and go ahead and
what were you going to say about the the
flaws go ahead I want to hear it well
I'm just saying your flaw specifically
is of course over the years cuz you know
you have a thing with women some deep
seening issues surrounding women babe
what um I mean without getting like too
Nitty Gritty about it but you have had
some misconceptions about women that
when I've of course heard them heard you
discuss them with me and in coup's
therapy me and the therapist are both
like this you like actually you have to
stop doing that Meme face right I just
do it the whole time that you actually
believed that like when you said Sushi
gave you stomach AES and I thought you
were lying because you didn't want sushi
yeah because that's something that you
would
do ah you know what dude that g me still
be [__] bro listen all right look can we
talk about like pants or something sure
okay actually you need new ones no I
don't need new pants how dare you say I
need new pants when you know my pants
are ill as [__] and they're new okay a
lot of my pants are new okay I have uh
baggier ones and I have tighter ones and
I have short ones and I have [__]
crazy pants like [__] shorts like
shorts yeah right and then I have crazy
cool kind of pants and different
patterns sure so I want you to actually
take that back okay I take it back okay
so but it's so the other thing
is uh you you love decorating you
actually you should talk about your uh
cozy robe uh YouTube channel cuz you cuz
you decorate for Christmas you got
makeup tutorial and you done a bunch of
other [__] yep and you're releasing
videos so anyway subscribe to her [__]
what is it uh cozy robe media cozy Rob
media cute dude yeah yo you really do be
decorating and people really do like
you're decorating man I kept telling you
to do this [__] yeah well I it's just a
lot of effort and I and I don't you know
what it is I put all the effort into the
decorating and into the thing into the
parties into the whatever I'm doing for
my kids and the idea of then filming it
and putting it online is like it's a
process well that's just something I
don't enjoy doing so I'm trying to find
a way to enjoy it like I only enjoy
doing the thing like I enjoy doing the
activity with Cal but then like totally
get it filming it and editing it it's
like I don't want to you know what I'm
say when I shoot my special mhm I'm done
after that you have to edit it you have
to do all the [__] I don't want to they
send me the link they say hey can you
look at this and I go yeah and I don't
look at it I go to the director who was
Matt you know and I say oh uh Sam too
directed it but I say is it good and
they go yeah dude at the last minute I
was like I I have to watch this I have
to I watched it and I realized that they
used a part in a in this in the second
show and I was like oh it was way better
than the first show and I was like you
guys can we move it and they moved it
and it was so much better I almost let
it go I don't want to do the after [__]
so bad because it's about the time that
you have in the room and the process of
creating what you're creating but dude
that when I have to make a special I I
don't I don't I don't care I I feel like
like Chris Rock did it live I feel like
that's cool like the problem is you'd be
so good at that the problem is It
suffers though like it definitely
suffers that way like cuz Chris Rock
recut it and made it the way he wanted
to make it after it was live mhm and and
like if I didn't do what I did it would
have SU suffered yeah but I I just I I I
I don't want to do stuff I don't want to
do so bad yeah that's the that's dude so
bad mhm
Sader well what the [__] though I know
like dude I
don't I don't want to do stuff that I
don't want to do so bad that I won't do
it for so long it'll cost me money it'll
cost me problems stress and I just won't
do it dude yeah up with that well you're
a therapist not yet but no remember when
I asked you um cuz when I was doing this
I filmed a makeup tutorial today yeah
and I asked people on my Instagram it's
Christen Taylor CA k s t i n and I asked
people to ask questions that were
therapy related it could be about them
could be about questions of my life
stuff like that but that's unlike you
but anyway it's all I think about as
human behavior but I know
um I asked you one of the questions that
I kept get getting that was repeated
which was how do I get my husband to
either go to couple's therapy or to just
do regular therapy on his own and you
are the king of like not wanting to do
stuff that you don't want to do so I was
like as someone who's now quote unquote
therapized you see the benefits of it
even though you went in kicking and
screaming right what was the thing that
you said to me oh well I said two things
I said one there's only two options you
can only say hey uh I I want you to do
therapy if you if you don't do therapy I
can't be with you a boundary a boundary
yeah or you can try to be like yeah well
I mean oh no it's the quote from rehab
that you said that resonated with me
oh oh I didn't know you talk about that
um doing something that you keep doing
even though you want to do it could make
your life
worse you you have to stop and be like
wait this thing that I keep doing is
only making my life worse even though I
want to do it like you know people do
heroin they love doing it they want to
do it but it's only making their life
worse yeah you if you don't do that and
do the things you don't want to do then
it will eventually make your life better
like not doing heroin and doing meetings
and doing you know recovery work if you
do that [__] even though you don't want
to it makes your life better and once
you realize and you're out of that
[__] spinning chaos yeah you know
that's what you should lead with now I
still you know don't want to do stuff
and I struggle with it but dude I was
there was there's the difference between
the thinking brain and the uh emotional
and and the wait the thinking brain and
the uh reptilian no no no no the
thinking brain and the
um
uh Rea what the [__] was it the thinking
brain and the it was it was it was about
um what was that book I was telling you
about not giving a [__] oh yeah um every
everything is
[__]
book thinking brain Chris did a meeting
the other day and he heard about a book
they Mark Manson he's great but and he
was talking about how much it meant to
me and it was so cute I was talking
about how much it meant to me well just
like the quotes that you're reading for
the book how it was like inspiring and
it was so cute hearing you talk about it
and the what brain emotional
brain I hate this that I don't know
dude oh wait here hold
on um let just cut that no we don't have
to cut it I mean we're looking it up you
can talk oh wait the the the emotions
are my notes are it's hot as hell it's
so hot in here but that's how it is
though should have brought some feeling
brain the thinking bread and the brain
and the feeling brain that's what it
is and it was saying that
um you want to think you think the
thinking brain you you think the feeling
brain
is you think the thinking brain is in
control but it's not in control because
you think you're thinking it and you're
like oh but you still do the things that
you feel you want to do totally so it's
like you we have this fallacy of you
think that your thinking brain is in
charge but it's not and you just have to
realize that it's a balance between the
two of them and when one is turned on
and when one is turned off and whatever
anyway that so it was it was interesting
but um and I'm not good at retelling
stuff but on my feet yes you are I am oh
my gosh you're the best well I'm good at
retelling stuff for a comedy sake yeah
but not not for like if I no you really
are I cuz I think deep down I'm I'm I'm
dumb know and so I don't I I I I get
like insecure and I I start being like
oh this is make a joke of it that was
like one of the biggest um like mind
blown deeper mind blown moments when you
when I found out that you like deep down
thought you were dumb well I think I'm
really smart when it comes to certain
things I know but not that's not how
smart things that's it's not how it
works yeah okay sure I guess what you're
saying you're smart you're smart is that
why you don't want to do things you
don't want to apply yourself because
then it would like not I mean maybe in
some instances yes but but
but right
because well I was think I was thinking
about this today like the the thinking
brain on that I
overthink and a lot of my therapy in the
last couple years has
been understanding how I react after
some kind of Crisis like I don't I
immediately go into thinking planning
managing how can we fix X Y and Z
thinking that I have some sort of
control over what's going to happen and
wanting so bad for the worst thing not
to happen and trying my very best but
really what I should be focusing all the
energy on because there's very little
that you can actually do is bettering
myself and getting to a better
soens matter good orad I'm in integrity
and I can trust myself and I know how to
move forward and that's energy much
better spent foreign oh I was trying to
think of the right way to word it but oh
that's energy much better rather than
like trying to manipulate my environment
and fix people and change people and
change things and like that's
so first of all it doesn't work usually
you can't change anyone and very rarely
can you change your environment if
something is happening but you can
change
yourself yeah I guess so you're talking
about uh like the trans
issues no yeah you can change yourself
into a female or a male I think that was
what they're trying to say except for
people on Fox News don't say that sure
sure sure uh yeah so anyway I'm I'm a
I'm a I'm a male I'm a red-blooded
American male you
know hell yeah you know what I'm saying
Hell yeah I'm a red blooded American
male I'm from the south you are is my
accent good uh it's not the southern
than I'm used to but yeah but when you
get down south when you get real down
south boy you run into my kind no you do
like your ass too sharp it's like very
loose what it's like what the [__] did
you just say to me hey sweetheart how
are you it's not like hey sweetheart how
are you hurt hey sweetheart no like hey
sweetheart hey sweetheart hey sweetheart
hey sweetheart yeah how are you what the
[__] did you just say to me
sweetheart hey chivalry may not be dead
but you're about to be if you talk to me
again like that oh is that good was that
sexy that sexy but but but I was
threatening you so that's not sexy right
what is it though you know what I mean
why do women like a guy that's like like
I was watching that SW squid games
Challenge and I'm like the dude in it
that's the dick the 432 number 432 that
dude that was just but like that's the
guy you'd [__] here's the thing there we
go she's got the thing locked and loaded
I want to know well cuz that's a guy
you'd [__] no okay but this is going
back to like the flawed thinking because
your your aim for years and years and
years and years and years was to be the
guy that girls
[__] right yeah but that's what you
you look for that in a guy as being like
the holy for like what a woman would
want but it's just because she's
initially attracted to that like
dominant energy doesn't mean that she
actually wants to like be with them or
even that she even likes them like I can
think of guys in my past were just like
douchebags but like they were hot and
like you know whatever dude you never
had sex with anyone until I came along
because I'm the man but you don't walk
away from those experiences being like
Oh that was like he was so sweet and
lovely like the guy that I remember from
my past is not a guy that I like really
hooked up with it was a guy that took me
out of my first date his name was Dave
he's an angel he's married now with a
baby dork no and he walked me to he
walked up to my door brought me flowers
on our first date took me to dinner was
so kind and that's like the thing that
actually you you want but why didn't and
you hooked up with them years and years
and years later man that flower game it
takes a long time
huh I know I brought you flowers HH and
then and then so you did late years
later though yeah nice well not not even
really I think we just kissed I can't
remember oh even remember dude yeah see
that's how not memorable he was dude I
bet you remember the dude that was bab
I'm telling you about the most memorable
thing yo what up Ma wow you have that
what's that thing where the bias
confirmation bias confirmation I have
genius um what uh I have confirmation
bias M yeah dude I'm all in with that
confirmation bias well we all are really
yeah but me
okay dude I'm just saying man you know
it's
like a man for years it's just been like
man I'mma wet it up you know what's that
mean well like I'm going to make people
really attracted to E Yeah Isn't that
cool no you're dad
now I'm not trying to make people
attracted now yeah but it's just like I
am what I am man sure I'm a little
fat so you think I have body dysmorphia
it's either
or the most black and white guy of all
time just no room I am 43 I
want I want to be more fit but you keep
making pasta so what's up
dude oh God what's up in the mic what's
up honey you're not fat okay I'm not fat
the only alarming thing is as someone
who has been with you for a very long
time when you get obsessed with things
things can go arai dude and you in the
gym it's like I love the gym an absolute
Love Story which is great for like
you're working out you're feeling better
about yourself your mental Health's
great it it's giving you endorphins all
these great things but it's more the
amount of time that I see focused on it
like you're on the couch watch scrolling
like buff guys like looking to see
you're putting it on YouTube like
whatever cow's watching you like switch
it out so you can watch this guy do
curls mom workouts yeah it's like a very
you are like so go hard I get I go 100
miles an hour or Z miles hour I have I I
I I do dude kind like that too maybe
that's why we get yeah yeah yeah but I
do stuff at the gym that people come up
to me and they go like what are you
doing and I say you don't know nothing
about this bro do you feel pride in
that I'm mostly want people to leave me
alone at the gym so no people call up to
be all the time at the gym
no they say they're fans and that's nice
or they say are you using that and
that's fine cuz it's a quick one no not
using that go ahead bro or Nah I
actually am using that but you want to
jump in always you want to jump in cuz
when I go to the gym and I see somebody
using an equipment and I say hey man how
many more you got left than that and
they go I just started and they don't
ask if I want to jump in oh your boy
gets [__]
hot your boy gets hot let me what's up
you got the leg extensions going on I
don't see another leg extension thing
here so let me jump in with you bro
you're just going to sit on there in
your
brakes I get real passionate about [__]
man and you know what happens when I go
to the gym with you two things one you
want me to work out with you but I get I
get intimidated over and the guy things
it's just like I know but like there's I
can't exp I I know you know what it is
it's I'll never understand it's just
being a woman is it because like you're
just constantly on alert I feel like I'm
like having to like watch my back and
look everywhere and there's like just
guys like buff and whatever yeah you
have to worry about getting kidnapped
and [__] yeah isn't that weird though
like I've never been kidnapped if you're
walking up a staircase and there's a
[__] dude walking down a staircase
you go this is it this is where I get
taken I don't go like that yeah I go
like this this is where I take this man
do you know what I'm going to take this
man you know I wonder if this is an
that's the guy we have in our bedroom
who the guy I
took from the Lowe's stairwell Lowe's
yeah was it Lowe's when I got the
generator anyway you would never get a
low I I got the generator at Lowe's so
jokes on you I made you go though okay
well and I didn't want to and I didn't
want to so bad right but I wonder if
this is the thing with all women or just
with me but whenever I'm in a situation
where I clock a guy that either is
looking too long or I just get a weird
feeling about I know all girls
experience that but I always say some
version of the same thing to myself and
I'm like I hope this [__] tries
me right now I hope to God the blackid
like what you [__] put bells
here that's [__]
up you know that Meme
though no can we can we put that in slow
motion with like
a a thing behind it but but but what the
[__] is the thing you put bells behind
my head The Way You Walk just an idiot
well dude I mean I didn't even know this
was here it's fine it's wi but you put
[__] big bells behind my head you
tried to uh booby trap
me oh babe now this see this is the
thing where it's like me by element just
relax just relax it's all what does it
even say Joy love peace believe
Christmas ho ho ho that's okay but what
were we talking about
though no dude oh I hope people try me
why cuz he'll just take you no it's it's
I you'd have to pee all over yourself no
I don't actually want that it's that I'm
hyping I hope this [__] takes me
I'll live with this [__] I'm
going to decorate his house so hard oh
dude I wish this [__] would take
me his house needs help I have so many
different game plans of what I would say
and do you you go take off the thing be
like you need a Fus over
there plug in some lights over there
trust me trust
me
this place will benefit from Lance it
has too much overhead
[Music]
lighting oh we have to kill her we
didn't even want to but she's just
trying to decorate the place too much no
they would like it oh so anyway what
were you saying about the you I wish
they would why I wish they would oh I
think it's like my way of like hyping up
like if I have to actually be in that
situation you should there also
something if I'm with Cal like and that
happens this feeling that comes over me
like if someone were to even come yeah 3
in away from me I feel like I could
superh human like Bo that's not a real
thing I know but I think that in my in
my head my point is piss yourself if
something happens because nobody wants
to take somebody all
pissy piss the honest God and [__] if
you can that's the least of their
worries and some guys are into that okay
what if it's the not the least of their
worri the Killer and then I just
absolutely screwed myself jizzes and he
goes oh never mind you know I'll get
someone else dude I want to go back to
you're saying that's the least of their
worries that's never the least of
anyone's worries if you [__] your pants
and then the guy has to deal with that
you said [__] your pants I said piss
and [__] well unlike you I can't go
potty on command out of my bum and who's
going to live a long healthy life
without getting taken because I can [__]
immediately if some dude tries to take
me as they Chlor form me I
go
just [__] and they I wake up in the
stairwell just like I knew that would
work just stink so bad my own [__] wakes
me up I can [__] whenever I want I can
do it right now have we talked about
this on the podcast I don't think yeah
yeah we've talked about on the podcast
yeah have we I I no I we can poop on
demand no you have talked about it on
Instagram I think but not the podcast
but I can Instagram whatever it was you
posted a story about it or something
like that you people know about it just
the little turd on the toilet no that's
disgusting people know about it I can do
that whenever I want I think I've talked
about on my on theast without you yeah
okay well let's just revisit the story
okay okay cuz it's a quick one you said
that you could go potty out of your bum
on demand I don't even like saying poop
it's gross I don't I don't like that you
know what I like worse than poop
poo yeah it's like finish the word
that's disrespectful okay I'll just say
potty out of your bum and you said that
you could go potty out of your bum on
demand and I said there's no way cuz
that's not a thing that people can do
and you said yes I can and I said then
do it right now and you said are you
serious I said said yeah and you went in
there and I heard like and then 4
minutes later there was just a little
little baby turd I evacuated a little
bit of it yeah it was I was shocked and
in awe I'm about my business man yeah
that's good though I go I go like five
sometime I go five times a day sometimes
I mean I have gone more than that you
know no diarrhea not even diarrhea not
even because I have a problem like I'm
eating clean and I still just my [__] is
a well oil machine okay so what were we
going to say to say the other thing that
I'm embarrassed about when I go to the
gym when I go with you
okay our gym is fairly large yeah don't
say which gym though of course yeah
and
I can hear this man no matter where I am
if I am on the treadmill if I am on the
stair stepper if I'm doing curls
whatever I'm doing I hear this man and
he is so loud making the loudest noises
like I don't give a [__] it's
like like that that it's so embarrassing
it's do am I really that loud dude H I
don't give a [__] am I babe for real
though I try to make it less in my head
to get the embarrassment to be less am I
really really loud for real you're the
loudest by far I don't give a
[__] you sure that was me
though yeah oh doesn't matter I don't
give a [__] but I'll tell you what why
do you do that because it's so I'll tell
you why there's one
reason it's not easier
it doesn't make you
stronger it is so nice that's why it
feels so nice remember when you would do
the rubbing and I would go and You' be
like don't do that it makes cuz you
thought I was doing it to make you know
that I like it so you would keep doing
it sweetie the joke's on you yeah it
feels nicer to be expelling things
like when you're doing this I I'm into
it I like it feels better for me it
literally feels better for me dude yeah
it feels worse for me though yeah but
you're pleasing me in that moment so I
should do everything I need to honey
we're pleasing each other no and you're
touching me like this and doing like
that kind of stuff yeah that's for
that's for
me and I go even just doing that right
now it makes me want to stop hold
on that feels nice so when I work out
and I'm putting the weight down and I go
or whatever it is that shit's nice that
shit's nice yeah I respect you well I
don't but you only respect me because I
don't give a [__] about it no I respect
you because I respect you because you're
my husband and I'm trying to learn how
to let you just be you as long as it's
not hurting our family [__] I'm
me you know what I mean and and when I
do that I
go and I put the weights down other guys
do it too dude but and I don't even care
if they do or not I try not to drop the
weights you know but anyway dude I go
[__] hard man dude remember when we
were lifting weights and already you had
like a little area that was like 4x4 and
it was already just like had like two
dirty towels a dumped over water bottle
all the way and I was like cleaning up I
was like some baseball cards and old hat
yeah d i you're a tornado I that's my
area dude I go I don't dude that's my
area and you know what it you know what
it doesn't need decorating that's what
it doesn't need it's my area for me I
got some [__] weight on there it's
just being uh courteous what being
courteous by like picking up your dumped
over I do pick up everything afterwards
I don't leave weights around every now
and then I leave weight around but I
figure if it's a lightweight I'm like ah
somebody might want it there yeah they
might come up be like this is exactly
where I wanted it yeah 15 lbs [__] it
but dude I'm not really using 15 PBS
much yeah but yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
something I need to work on I need to
work on letting you do whatever I want
whenever I want want to I agree I need
to work on letting you be you and it's
not hurting anybody anyone's heart what
is that hurting yeah anybody's heart I
need to work on like if you're going to
be the loudest man in the gym yeah it's
okay well has no bearing on me you know
who's so good at that my friend Jillian
and I always respect her oh she's
mentioning another friend all right so
go what up with Jan we love is so good
at letting people be exactly who they
are that is true she is very good at
that good at that and I would love to
take a little of that and learn more of
it you're pretty good at that I know no
I'm pretty good but I want to be better
you're such a specific man that this
comes up a
lot I am specific huh well [__] God damn
it you know I don't know but
boy do I love you oh that's sweet I do
that's really really uh
sweet do I feeling I deserve to be
L do I feel like I'm not enough most of
the time and when somebody says they
love me I feel weird and I want to make
a joke about
it uh remember what I was talking about
that made me think of
the what was I talking wer we just
talking about some [__] where lifting
weights being no no no where somebody
was
um wen't we just talking about when
somebody older it's all how you look at
life and then there's negative people
that just are negative in their older
age and then there's people who are just
positive in their older age weren't we
just talking about that squid game that
sweet old lady yes dude yes yes
yeah wow we figured it out I did not
think we were going to figure that out
but the squid squid Game Challenge the
old lady in the squid Game Challenge we
should clarify like the new it's the new
squid Game Challenge what it's called
yeah the squid game is called squid game
um but yes the new one squid Game
Challenge yeah it's the woman who is the
older lady and she's just like dealing
with people and like it's just age can
bring that to you yeah but it doesn't
always totally sometimes life attacks
you and you get this victim mentality
and you're like [__] these
[__] and I be like that's where
I'm headed I'm trying to be a little bit
of a more even keeled Larry David you
know what I'm saying and it's just I'm
just headed straight towards Larry
Davidsville and I want to be a little
more forgiving a little more uh
openminded and openhearted and I'm just
not honestly babe if you think about
where you were three and a half years
ago to where you are now I would say
that's an exponential up it's a spiral
staircase true yeah true you're doing so
much better I am doing better we're
living and learning baby
that's all life is living and learning
yeah it's not about the destination it's
about the journey dude I hope I end up
with somewhere really cool though even
though it's not about the destination
you know where I can't wait to go and
end up and I want to stop this
conversation right now because I think I
know what you're going to say and the
answer is I'll see you when you get back
no what do you think I don't even want
to say it cuz if it's if it's what I
don't think and I say the thing then
you're going to want to talk about that
too and I don't even want to bring that
up well too wait baby I already know
what you're talking about the missou
game no I know what you're talking about
no that's not what I was going to say oh
really I was going to say [__] we're
talking about living and learning and
anything this is levels dude it's like
we're in the van falling down in the
[__] except Inception yeah but you
know what I'm excited I don't want to go
to that bowl game but anyway go ahead
we're going to go n I'll see we get back
the zoo dude we have
kids babe I I have gone on trips with
our kids by myself yeah you have when
you're on the road I went to San Diego
right driving anyway go anyway go ahead
go ahead I every decade or so if anybody
listening to this is from Missouri knows
missou every you know everybody from
Missouri because every time I bring up
somebody you're like that person went to
missou if they did well they all go to
missou John Ham I know about these
[__] the sexies dude the sexies
Brad Pit has a um a composite like a
little freshman picture and it's in a
you know the big picture with all of his
freshman class and it always gets stolen
every year by people they and John Ham
has a big [__]
right you see the the pictures of him
when his big dick flopping around yeah
you've seen it right oh yeah because you
and you know why you've seen it because
you went to missou that's why you've
seen it no I've seen it because
everyone's seen
it I feel like you know about it because
you went to missou and he went to mizou
and he came up in your timeline because
of mizou stuff and you were like oh that
guy's got a big dick in his
khakis I actually you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna spoil
something dude I don't think that you
can tell if a guy has a big dick in
pants or not unless it's abnormally
large obviously you can tell if it's a
huge Third Leg but like the stuff I saw
with John Ham I'm like it could still be
a not that big dick is that the guy in
you that just wants him to have no
absolutely not no dude no it's not no
you know me I don't give a [__] I want
dudes to have big dicks right up their
ass no I'm kidding but but but but I
want dudes to have their dicks have your
big dick I need it too but I'm just
saying there's a thing that sometimes a
dick looks big because it's actually
small and it's not doing the hangover
thing right it's not getting to the
point where it's too long where
gravity's taking it over a notch and
it's just poking out so it makes this
tent like pop thing and it makes it look
like it's a big dick but really it just
ends right there exposing himself for
having a tiny penis sweetheart I got an
elephant trunk but what what I'm saying
is no you know I do fine but like I I I
am saying that that does that that does
happen and I'm not saying that that's
what John Ham John H probably has a big
dick he walks around like he's got it
like that you know
but there are misconceptions with that
that is great to know thank you so much
for enlightening me on that you're very
welcome we talk about the heart eating
issues now what was the thing that you
were going to bring
up um not the not the bowl game yeah I
was going to say that I am very excited
for nursing home when I'm a an El Elder
when I'm a for being in a nursing home
yeah I'm
stoked I'm going who even thinks you
know what this is you know what this is
we just found out you're
artistic that's like remember in the
what what was the Love on the Spectrum
when he was going to get when he was
going to go out on the date with the
first girl he's like like so what's they
going be like like I don't know I had
this I had this me this vision of you
know what she would say at my funeral
when I died when I was older and it's
like oh my God that's what you're
doing yeah I mean I definitely have the
thing where I I definitely have the
thing where I don't
um know what I say if it's good or bad I
just say all the things so hold on
you're excited to be in a nursing home
yeah just go
now no I I'll visit you and I'll be
there I think it's because i' I'm I
don't mean I don't want I don't mean I
want you away from me I just mean like
go babe what I mean is let move to
Florida
I think I've always been so terrified of
death terrified like I used to have um
dreams when I was a kid I mean
everyone's scared of death when they say
they're not it's it's lies no but mine
was like unusual where I would talk
about it often and my mom was like a
little alarmed right just the idea of
like dying and not existing is like so
terrifying and just aging too I was
scared of old people me too really oh
yeah scared of like 90-year-old like
ladies like they dying yeah I know it's
scary oh that's funny I didn't know that
was like a typical thing I don't know if
it's typical but well there you go match
man hell oh wow um but anyways I think
over the years I've like tried to think
about what that time would be like in my
life to try and make it better and I've
come up with a plan and now the plan
sounds really fun I'm going to go to a
nursing home you're 10 years older than
me you're probably going to croak before
I go just I'm 43 yeah I'm more I'm 12
years older than you 11 11 okay uh or 10
yeah whatever it changes I know we're on
birthdays in the same day um but what
were you saying but you're going to die
before me so I'm going to be alone which
is going to be really sad but I'm going
to go to a nursing unless you keep
[__] daring dudes to take you in a
stairwell then you'll die first that's
true okay okay so go ahead but if the
more likely thing will happen I'm going
to go to a nursing home one of those
like really the more likely things is
going to happen is I'm going to get hit
by a bus when I'm walking across the
street
texting I know that is true don't make
it real babe you got to be better at
that but let me finish all I'm going to
go to a nursing home a nice one I'm
going to work really hard once I get my
degree and whatever I end up doing I'm
going to work really hard and make a
fund for my retirement and it's so I can
go to a nice nursing home with a golf
cart have little condos and I'm going to
make all of my friends go there too and
then we're going to play Bingo together
I already love it we're gonna play uh
cards together I already love that we're
gonna play puzzles together I already
love that you don't have to say already
love that you but I'm was just saying
even in my youth I like that so like
okay got it that's going to and it's
going to be a lovely way to go I'll have
no idea where I am I'll just know that
I'm around people that I love and it's
going to be great I'm not going to make
my kids take care of me because I don't
want that oh dude I don't want to be a
burden
[__]
what I'm going to like when I I I I I'll
do that that too but I need like I need
like well I guess I'll be dead already
is what you're saying no maybe not I
would I mean I would love if you you
know what I would love if you stayed
alive um I don't know if you do croak
but I'd love if you stayed alive if you
can make it that'd be great come to
Florida with me with my friends um
wouldn't it be fun to have a golf cart
and I could decorate it we could just do
that now though P it up well I don't I
I'm just saying that that situation will
be tough because your life is behind you
mostly and so I'm trying to make the
most of that oh I get it I'm not saying
that I'm like thrilled to do that right
now but yeah it doesn't seem so bad when
I put it that way yeah I'm sure it's fun
yeah it it'll be fun I'll do it but
you'll be too young you'll be too young
cuz I'll be like 80 and you'll be like
69 and I'll be like babe I got to go to
the retirement
home you could just chill for a bit I'll
me you meet me there when you get there
you know and then I know that's sad we
we don't know what's gonna happen right
right I'll get bus texting but
whatever it is we're working on
ourselves we're growing or dying and
it'll be okay okay but don't die don't
don't be texting while you're driving
you no I the joke was I was walking
across the street texting not being okay
it's funnier that way and that's
okay don't be texting okay right I
understand
now we're not going to that bowl
game
what wife has to fight her husband this
is an argument that I don't even it's
not even a thing to have to go to a bowl
game this is just something that is just
that I went I went to college here my
mom went to college there both of my
grandparents went to college there my
grandma was on the homecoming court
missou court isn't that cute that is
cute yeah little pict I'll give you that
that is cute in the' 40s yearbook and
it's really ominous cuz it was like rest
in peace to all these people that had
gone off to wor and died oh [__] Jesus
it's not that cute I mean it's come more
aw remind me um Christmas I'll show it
to you I think it's at Lynn's house ly
Remind You Christmas to show you
something ominous okay go ahead I love
om I love it I love an ominous Vibe
during the holidays but I want to go to
this bow game I love competitive Sports
because you were a competitive gymnast
yeah I mean you know you were yeah well
no I'm I thinking if that's really why I
do like to compete and I love the feel
of winning well that's because of being
a you were like a top gymnast yeah but
I'm not like competitive f with like
things that I do it's more like
watching yeah but you were competitive
when you competed sure yeah that's what
that's from yeah but I just mean like in
my DayDay life I'm not like a
competitive person no you're not a
competitive person in day-to-day life
but when you do games you are sure and I
think some people would call me a fair
weather fan cuz I grew up in North
Carolina you are a fair weather watched
the Carolina Panthers and hurricanes yes
had season tickets it was great you're a
fair weather fan went to missou whole
family went to missou so I like them you
also just want people who are winning to
be winning well that's the thing and
then why do you do that I just want to
make sure it's loving and not assault go
ahead and then I moved to LA and like
our kids are from here we're you know
but here's the thing I don't have time
to be anything but a fair weather fan
yeah I get that I got a husband that a
child I got two babies I have a home to
husband that's a
child there's like if you're not doing
great this is why exactly and this is
why she's going to divorce me for
exhaustion later on because I don't have
time I don't have time and then oh
[__] oh honey what the [__] I'm
divorcing you why because of exhaustion
why because because I watch too many
bowl games that's why I went to
Michael's too much I bet 40 people that
are listening to this are like he's
exhausting no I bet oh I bet thousands
of people are like we get get it Chris
dude I these the people the listeners
dude they're the [__] they're we are
this is a cult dude and we're going to
be sitting in the tall grass and we are
going to be in a log cabin and just
sharing ideas and it's going to be so
dope that's what I want when I'm older
so if I get to the retirement community
first I'll do that it'll be a log cabin
we'll be sharing ideas I'll have a beard
it'll be crazy can I have a golf
cart yeah can I have little condos right
next to all my friends and make them
come make them come like
busting make them come to the law cabin
yeah okay I'm there no busting can I
decorate the Log Cabin yes rustic like
very log [__] Log Cabin yes of course
let's do it babe all right I'm done this
is just off the rails and I'm so tired
and I'm so hot anyway dude thank you
very much oh get my special grower die
chris.com and also get tickets man I'm
going to be everywhere yeah you know
know what I mean Phoenix Phoenix I can't
wait to get to Phoenix and uh sorry can
I say something about your special at
the end okay this special I've watched
him work it for the last couple of years
it's the best
coolest thing he's ever done it's so
[__] funny and he talks about so much
of the stuff that we went through in an
amazing way and I'm so [__] proud of
you thanks babe way to go thank you it's
the coolest thing ever thank you I could
watch it every single day till I die and
I will you always bring death into it oh
yeah okay congrat thank you I appreciate
that a lot of people have probably
already seen it but uh if you haven't
check it out uh and uh thank you very
much like And subscribe to this YouTube
channel and hers too uh and I appreciate
you thank you guys
[Music]
bye
[__] [__]
me